foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
delicious
I will
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
thanks
hello where's your number
no no no no no no Hector we told you
after last time no more that was just my
song and dance routine my new actor will
blow your minds prepare yourself for the
dance the foes of pigeons
[Music]
that that's enough thank you
maybe maybe go back to singing
security
[Music]
seriously dude
ditch the birds you got to show them
something they've never seen before
that was ain't working
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hi
I'm looking for something something
unusual
but cute really really cute also
affordable
that I can I can fit under my hat
why I'm dancing
we got a special and bird eating spiders
okay let's try this again oh a
constrictor
vampire bat
might have a lemur in the back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
I like it like that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
At Your Service
oh
favorite Disney friend welcome home
we're family now
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's go
[Music]
Allah love
come on Lyle I know you don't talk but
you can't sing
[Music]
la la la la
foreign
[Music]
shuts down but when the world sends you
ain't quite world renowned don't count
yourself out yet
it's the only way left to go you're
meant to reinvent the show so ain't your
glad to be that turn that fall of dust
[Music]
maybe we started pretty small but take a
look at us now take a look at us now
suddenly starting Ten Feet Tall take a
look at us now take a look at us now
though we had no way to stay here
[Music]
so take a look at us now
you already owe me for the last show yes
but this one's special then you pay me
up front in cash maybe uh problem but
something far more valuable
[Music]
when I'm perfect
[Music]
if you're out of sync if you care too
much with those critics think well when
you find your list
[Music]
foreign
got a full house out there brick leg